I'm gonna fire Bachelor questions are
you ready Bachelorette questions one who
do you want is the next Bachelor I know
we don't know the outcome but if you're
gonna pick who you guys picking I think
Peters super cute I think you'd be a
good bachelor right I got my eyes on you
Peter yeah let's go with Peter because
Cass thinks he's really cute yeah no I
think I think Peters Peter has to work
on his moves oh did you see him try to
pick her up for that pool table thing we
were like I wouldn't it wasn't that
smooth but he could get there who's your
pick for her Hannah oh geez I think I
honestly there's a group of four or five
really solid dudes that are like good
for her I like her dynamic with Jed I
like her dynamic with Tyler too so
people we're comparing Luke P to you
saying you guys look alike do you see
that I don't know what do you think he's
got to work on he's really villainizing
himself on the show yeah you know he's
made a lot of mistakes don't get me
wrong but you know the show is all about
you know staying true to yourself I
haven't seen any extreme red flags yet I
mean he's not very self-aware on camera
which isn't a bad thing he's just not
he's not used to being on a TV show I
think there's a lot we don't see to know
so it was hard - any advice you'd give
him he's gonna have to tune out some
noise because it's not you know went
through our fair share of people hating
on us
it could be borne out
so you just he just has to stick with
this family and his friends that were
there before the show and they're gonna
be with him after last questions for you
paradise we're about to get it soon you
cried a lot on paradise cold and what
advice do you have for people going on
paradise food to take risks and let your
walls down and to bring an air
conditioner ibid I did bring my own air
conditioner it's still there I got word
Oh so the air conditioner it lives on
last question for you guys you've had so
many different moments in your
relationship do you have an anniversary
and if so like what did you pick up it's
just that you know this other day like
what's the exact date we go back I think
like November 17 can we ask you though
would it be the moment she stepped out
of the limo or would it be the finale in
Spain with us go finale
[Music]